This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For the last several months, I've been working on something with the Guggenheim Museum in New York. It's a brand new audio tour about the history and design of a truly great work of American architecture. Even if you've never been to the Guggenheim, you probably recognize it. From the outside, the building is a light gray spiral, and inside, the art is displayed on one long ramp that curves up towards a glass skylight in the ceiling. There's no museum like it, and it was made by one of my favorite architects, Frank Lloyd Wright.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯 (Roman Mars)。在过去的几个月里，我一直在和纽约的古根海姆博物馆合作一个项目。这是一个全新的语音导览，讲述了一部真正伟大的美国建筑杰作的历史与设计。即使你从未去过古根海姆，你也可能认出它。从外观上看，这座建筑是一个浅灰色的螺旋体，而在内部，艺术品则陈列在一条长长的坡道上，这条坡道一直向上弯曲，通向天花板上的玻璃天窗。没有哪座博物馆像它这样，它出自我最喜欢的建筑师之一弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特 (Frank Lloyd Wright) 之手。
What you're going to hear now is the whole audio tour. If you're in New York City, you should try and listen to it inside the museum. There are signs on every floor indicating where you should stop. But if you can't make it to New York, the tour is still really fun and works on its own. The team at the Guggenheim were generous enough to allow me to create a different kind of audio tour that feels like walking through the building with an extremely enthusiastic and knowledgeable friend rather than a formal architecture professor. I hope you like it.
你接下来听到的就是全部的语音导览。如果你身处纽约市，你应该试着在博物馆里面听它。每一层都有指示牌，告诉你应该在哪里驻足。但如果你去不了纽约，这个导览依然非常有趣，并且能够独立呈现。古根海姆的团队非常慷慨，允许我创作一种不同寻常的语音导览——与其说它像一位刻板的建筑学教授，不如说它更像是和一个极其热情且博学的朋友一起漫步在建筑中。希望你喜欢。
We're going to post an episode guide with photos on our website at 99 professor. I hope you like it. We're gonna post an episode guide with photos on our website at 99pi.org so you can follow along at home. But I think you can close your eyes and imagine and still enjoy all the stories. Here's the first stop. If you're in the building start playing this in the lobby of the Rotunda. lobby of the Rotunda. Welcome to the Guggenheim Museum. I'm Roman Mars, the creator and host of the Design and Architecture Podcast 99% Invisible. The Guggenheim Museum is an architectural masterpiece made by a master of architecture, Frank Lloyd
我们将在我们的网站 99pi.org 上发布带有照片的剧集指南，这样你就可以在家中同步收听。但我认为你完全可以闭上眼睛想象，依然能尽情享受所有的故事。这是第一站。如果你在建筑内，请从圆形大厅的大堂开始播放。欢迎来到古根海姆博物馆。我是罗曼·马尔斯，设计与建筑播客《99% Invisible》的创作者兼主持人。古根海姆博物馆是由建筑大师弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特打造的建筑杰作。
Wright. In 2019, UNESCO selected eight buildings designed by Wright, including the Guggenheim, to be a World Heritage Site. UNESCO sites are considered vital to the collective interests of humanity. Yellowstone is a heritage site, so is the Grand Canyon. Of the World Heritage Properties in America, 12 were made by God. 8 were made by Frank Lloyd Wright. When co-founder and first director of the Guggenheim Museum, Hila Rebeck commissioned this building, she said she wanted a temple of spirit and right design one for her.
2019年，联合国教科文组织将赖特设计的八座建筑（包括古根海姆博物馆）选为世界遗产。联合国教科文组织的世界遗产被认为对全人类的集体利益至关重要。黄石公园是世界遗产，大峡谷也是。在美国的世界遗产中，12处由大自然鬼斧神工造就，8处由弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特设计。当古根海姆博物馆的联合创始人兼首任馆长希拉·丽贝克 (Hila Rebay) 委托设计这座建筑时，她说她想要一座精神圣殿，而赖特为她设计了一座。
Here's the director of the Guggenheim Richard Armstrong. I feel now when I look up into that dome, I'm actually looking at a very beautiful abstraction of a rose window in a cathedral. I'm in awe. So we're going to take the genius of this building as a given. It's great. What I'm going to focus on are the oddities, the accretions, the interventions that reveal a different kind of genius. Not just the genius of Frank Lloyd Wright and his bold original vision, but the genius of all the people that made this building function, adapt, and grow over the decades.
这是古根海姆的馆长理查德·阿姆斯特朗 (Richard Armstrong)。我现在看着那个穹顶时，感觉自己实际上是在看大教堂里非常美丽的玫瑰窗抽象画。我感到敬畏。因此，我们将这座建筑的天才之处视为理所当然。它太棒了。我要重点关注的是那些奇特之处、增生物以及各种介入改造，正是这些揭示了另一种不同类型的天才。不仅是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特及其大胆的原创远见的天才，还有几十年来让这座建筑得以运转、适应和发展的所有人的天才。
Frank Lloyd Wright was the originator of a concept called organic architecture. You might look around and see how this entire building resembles a seashell and you might think, oh, cool, that must be organic architecture. But sorry, that's actually not what he meant. Really, for Frank Lloyd Wright, organic architecture was more about the metaphor of a living organism. This is Ashley Mendelssohn, the Guggenheim's assistant curator of architecture and digital initiatives.
弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特是“有机建筑”概念的鼻祖。你环顾四周，可能会发现整座建筑多么像一个贝壳，然后你会想：“哦，酷，那一定就是有机建筑。”但抱歉，这实际上并不是他的意思。对弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特来说，有机建筑其实更多地关乎生物体的隐喻。这是古根海姆博物馆建筑与数字项目助理策展人阿什利·门德尔松 (Ashley Mendelssohn)。
And actually when he was on the site, he referred to the steel as the tendons and the muscles of the building, the concrete, as the fatty tissue, and the waterproof paint as the skin. So we're going to explore, touch, and even dance with this living organism of a building and witness the evolution that's occurred within these curved walls. The next stop is by the second floor elevators on the main ramp. Frank Lloyd Wright's plan was for the Guggenheim to be a top-down museum.
事实上，当他在工地上时，他将钢筋称为建筑的肌腱和肌肉，将混凝土称为脂肪组织，将防水漆称为皮肤。因此，我们将探索、触摸甚至与这座活生生的建筑跳一支舞，并见证在这道弯曲墙壁内发生的演变。下一站位于主坡道二楼的电梯旁。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的计划是让古根海姆成为一座自上而下的博物馆。
Originally, visitors were supposed to ride the elevator to the top of the spiral ramp and walk down. That's where the exhibitions all started. I've seen many images of old installation views from the 60s into the 70s, where that's where the intro text was. Initially, the exhibitions were planned from top down, starting on ramp five, get out of the elevator. The entrance name of the exhibition was right in front of you and you walked down to see it. But over time, curators started programming from the bottom up.
最初，参观者应该乘电梯到达螺旋坡道的顶部，然后步行向下参观。这也是所有展览开始的地方。我见过很多60年代到70年代的老装置艺术照片，引言文本就挂在那里。最初，展览是按自上而下的方式规划的，从五楼开始，走出电梯。展览的入口名称就在你正前方，你一路向下走去参观。但随着时间的推移，策展人们开始从下往上进行策展规划。
It just felt natural. But over time, curators started programming from the bottom up. It just felt natural. Also, the Guggenheim does a lot of retrospectives focusing on one artist from their early work to the late stuff. Many artists over the course of their career is their work got larger in scale. And so if you're doing a retrospective where you're starting with the early work which is small and then moving to larger work, it makes sense to start at the bottom because the display space is in the building get bigger and bigger as you
这感觉很自然。此外，古根海姆经常举办回顾展，聚焦于一位艺术家从早期作品到晚期作品的整个创作生涯。许多艺术家的作品在他们的职业生涯中规模越来越大。因此，如果你在做一个回顾展，从规模较小的早期作品开始，然后转向更大的作品，那么从底部开始就很有意义，因为当你向上移动时，建筑中的展示空间会变得越来越大。
move up in space. But if you want to be a Frank Lloyd Wright originalist and you really need to walk down from the top of the Guggenheim, you might have company as you ride up the elevator. I think still 15 to 20% of people take the elevator up. And it's probably because they heard that that's how Frank Lloyd Wright intended and they want to see it that way. And so most designers and curators plan for it to be experienced both ways. And in fact, most visitors that I talk to walk up and then walk down.
但如果你想成为弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的忠实原教旨主义者，并且非要从古根海姆的顶部向下走，你在乘电梯时可能会遇到同伴。我认为仍然有15%到20%的人会乘电梯上去。这可能是因为他们听说那是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特原本的意图，他们希望以这种方式来体验。因此，大多数设计师和策展人都计划让人们以两种方式来体验它。事实上，我交谈过的大多数游客都是先走上去，然后再走下来。
So it makes sense that the show should be able to read in both ways. This isn't the only big difference from how Frank Lloyd Wright envisioned the Guggenheim. His blueprints included plans for a second spiral ramp that would protrude out into the center of the rotunda. It was going to be twice as steep as the corkscrew ramp you were standing on right now. He called it the quick ramp and it was supposed to make it faster to get between floors. In Frank Lloyd Wright, in the description said, feel the pull of gravity as you walk down the ground ramp and for quick and easy access between ramps, take the quick ramp, which
所以，展览应该能以两种方式被解读，这是合情合理的。这并不是与弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特设想的古根海姆大相径庭的唯一重大区别。他的蓝图里还包括第二个螺旋坡道的计划，该坡道将凸出到圆形大厅的中心。它将比你现在站着的这条螺旋坡道陡峭两倍。他称之为“快速坡道”，本意是让楼层之间的通行更快。弗兰克·劳埃德在说明中写道：当你走普通坡道时，去感受重力的拉力；而为了在坡道之间进行快速便捷的通行，请走快速坡道……
is really good. But on the quick ramp, you'd feel gravity's pull a little too much. The design was way too steep. It was more like a quick slide, so it never got built. But the quick ramp still influenced the final design of the museum. You'll notice the hole in the center of the rotunda, it's not a perfect circle, and the ramp you're on right now is not a perfect spiral. There's a semi-circle that juts out into the rotunda.
这真的很棒。但在快速坡道上，你会过分感受到重力的拉力。这个设计实在是太陡了。与其说是坡道，倒不如说更像是一个快速滑梯，所以它最终没有被建造出来。但快速坡道仍然影响了博物馆的最终设计。你会注意到圆形大厅中心的那个洞并不是一个完美的圆形，你现在所在的坡道也不是一个完美的螺旋形。有一个半圆形突入了圆形大厅。
That's called the bump out. The bump out used to be part of the quick ramp. When you see that, then you understand that every curve actually belongs to a circle somewhere. They all had a reason for being there. Sadly, we missed out on the opportunity to slide our way down the Guggenheim. But the stairs we got as an alternative route between floors are still pretty delightful. You can find them
这被称为“凸出部”。这个凸出部曾经是快速坡道的一部分。当你看到这一点时，你就会明白，每一个曲线其实都属于某个圆。它们存在都有各自的理由。遗憾的是，我们错失了从古根海姆滑下去的机会。但作为楼层之间的替代路线，我们得到的楼梯依然非常令人愉悦。你可以在电梯门后面的走廊里找到它们。
in the hallways behind the elevator doors. They twist up the building in a triangle and add another lovely, pure form to the museum. The next stop is by the third floor elevators on the main ramp. As you walk up the ramp in the rotunda, place your hand on the parapet that's the low wall separating the ramp from the void in the center. The first thing you'll notice is that it's very low. If it were built today, let's be honest, it would probably be a couple inches taller. The other thing you'll notice is that even though the building is composed of these pure forums like circles and spirals, the top of
它们呈三角形盘旋向上，为博物馆增添了又一种可爱而纯粹的形态。下一站位于主坡道三楼的电梯旁。当你沿着圆形大厅的坡道往上走时，把手放在胸墙上——那是将坡道与中心虚空隔开的矮墙。你注意到的第一件事就是它非常低。老实说，如果是今天建造的话，它可能会高出几英寸。你会注意到的第二件事是，尽管这座建筑由圆圈和螺旋等纯粹的形态组成，但胸墙的顶部并不是完全圆润的，也没有以锐利的直角收尾。它凹凸不平。
the parapet isn't perfectly rounded or finished off with a crisp right angle. It's bumpy and uneven. So the reason why the parapet is kind of lumpy in that way is because we touch up paint truly every day when the museum's not open and that's because the building is white and so it gets dirty. You'd have to really close the whole building and have it closed for, you know, I don't know, a full week or something
胸墙之所以会呈现出那种块状的凹凸不平，是因为在博物馆不开放的时候，我们真的每天都在进行补漆。这是因为建筑是白色的，所以很容易变脏。如果你真的要彻底粉刷室内，你不得不将整楼关闭，关闭整整一周左右……
if you were to truly repaint the interior and so instead, we touch up here and there and for that reason, everything kind of has a texture. You have an effect on this building. By being here and touching this railing, you've changed it. It's changing texture is part of its evolution as an organic structure. Okay, stay right here. This is the second stop on the third floor.
因此，我们只能在这里和那里进行修补，正因如此，一切都带有一种质感。你对这座建筑有着影响。通过来到这里并触摸这根栏杆，你已经改变了它。它不断变化的质感是它作为有机结构演变的一部分。好了，就站在这里。这是三楼的第二站。
Constructing Frank Lloyd Wright's vision of a spiral museum was not an easy feat to pull off. Right oversaw the work, but a local architect named William Short was in charge of the project on the ground, and George Cohen was the general contractor. In the three years it took to build the Guggenheim. They came to the realization that some of Wright's ideas were not going to be doable. Like the idea of making the building a self-supporting spiral. If you imagine a slinky or something in the way that the wire,
实现弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特关于螺旋博物馆的构想绝非易事。赖特监督了这项工作，但一位名叫威廉·肖特 (William Short) 的当地建筑师负责现场项目，乔治·科恩 (George Cohen) 则是总承包商。在建造古根海姆的三时间里，他们意识到赖的一些想法是无法实现的。比如将建筑做成一个自支撑螺旋的想法。如果你想象一个弹力玩具或类似的东西，电线由于处于那种张力中而将自身维系在一起，他在早期就是这么说的。
just because it's in tension in that way is holding itself together, that's what he said early on. So instead of a self-supporting spiral, they use something called web walls. Look at the floor across from you. Those thin walls that you see that jut out from floor to ceiling, those are actually all connected. Those are the web walls. They hold this whole building together. These vertical walls, which extend all the way up into the Oculus, the combination of all of those together is the structural skeleton of the building, everything else hangs off of it.
因此，他们没有采用自支撑螺旋，而是使用了一种叫做“网墙”的东西。看看你对面的地板。你看到的那些从地板延伸到天花板的薄墙，其实都是连在一起的。那些就是网墙。它们将整座建筑维系在一起。这些垂直的墙壁一直延伸到天窗（Oculus）中，所有这些墙壁的组合就是建筑的结构骨架，其他一切都悬挂在它上面。
The ramp hangs off of it, the exterior wall is hanging off of it. They had to solve the problem of making a curving spiral building no one had even imagined before, much less built, and they did it with gunite. Gunite is concrete that is shot out of a hose at high velocity. You spray it against a mold, it dries real fast, and takes on the shape of the mold. It was right to idea to use this pretty novel technology when the building was constructed. If you look closely and the sun is just right, you can see an angled checkerboard pattern
坡道悬挂在它上面，外墙也悬挂在它上面。他们必须解决建造一个从未有人想象过、更不用说建造过的弯曲螺旋建筑的难题，而他们用的是喷射混凝土（gunite）。喷射混凝土是通过软管高速喷射出来的混凝土。你把它喷在模具上，它干得非常快，并呈现出模具的形状。在建造这座建筑时，采用这种相当新颖的技术是赖特的想法。如果你仔细观察，而且阳光刚好合适，你可以看到一个倾斜的棋盘格纹理……
of lines that betray the form of the plywood molds that created the shape of the outer wall. They had hired a subcontractor to do the gunite and because they didn't think about the formwork being expressed, the gunite formwork is placed on like a real angle which is not consistent. It's just because they didn't think you would see it, and so they just made their pattern work as you do. The pattern is a result of the gun-ite construction, and Frank Lloyd Wright didn't like the fact that it was visible.
这些线条暴露出构成外墙形状的胶合板模具的痕迹。他们曾聘请分包商来做喷射混凝土，但因为他们没有考虑模板会显露出来，所以喷射混凝土的模板放置得非常倾斜且不一致。这只是因为他们觉得你看不到，所以就随手做出了那种纹理。这种纹理是喷射混凝土施工的结果，而弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特并不喜欢它被看见。
But George Cohen convinced him and actually exemplified the principles of architectural honesty that Frank Lloyd Wright and other modernists championed. In many ways, George Cohen is the under-song hero of the Guggenheim, but Frank Lloyd Wright's respect for him is clear. Right by the front entrance, George Cohen's name is written in metal, embedded on the exterior wall, alongside a red square that serves as Frank Lloyd Wright's signature. This was the only time Wright ever put the general contractor's name on a building. From the next stop, head over to the cafe off the ramp on the third floor. Look out the window and you'll see the outer facade up close.
但乔治·科恩说服了他，并且实际上体现了弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特和其他现代主义者所倡导的建筑诚实原则。在许多方面，乔治·科恩都是古根海姆幕后未被颂扬的英雄，但弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特对他的尊重是显而易见的。就在正门旁，乔治·科恩的名字用金属写成，嵌入在外墙上，旁边还有一个作为弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特署名的红方块。这是赖特唯一一次将总承包商的名字放在建筑上。从下一站出发，前往三楼坡道旁边的咖啡馆。望向窗外，你就能近距离看到外立面。
There are two cool things to know about the facade of the Guggenheim. First is the color. It's very different from when the building opened. It wasn't this whitish grey. It was more of a beji yellow. Frank Lloyd Wright called the original color buff. They're really great photos of that. It kind of almost looks more like a sand castle
关于古根海姆的外立面，有两个很酷的事情值得了解。首先是颜色。它与建筑刚开业时大不相同。它不是这种白灰色，而是更偏向米黄色。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特将最初的这种颜色称为“浅黄土色（buff）”。那里有一些非常棒的照片。它看起来几乎更像是一个沙堡。
has a very different feeling than it does now. To create buff, they use a special waterproof paint called cocoon. Eight years after the building opened, the exterior needed to be repainted. So the museum staff went to the manufacturer of cocoon paint and discovered they no longer had buff. So that original color buff was no longer on the market the first time they repaint
给人一种与现在截然不同的感觉。为了打造这种浅黄土色，他们使用了一种名为“可可”的特殊防水涂料。建筑开业八年后，外立面需要重新粉刷。于是博物馆员工找到了可可漆的制造商，却发现他们不再生产这种浅黄土色了。所以在他们第一次重新粉刷建筑时，这种最初的浅黄土色已经不在市场上销售了。
the building. So they ended up going with a slightly lighter shade and over the years they used a bunch of different colors more of a stark white and currently it's gray. People perceive that to be white but it's actually gray. After the building was awarded landmark status, the Guggenheim went through a restoration, and it created an interesting conundrum, paint-wise. Should the museum stick with the light gray everyone had grown accustomed to, or roll back time
因此，他们最终选择了一种稍浅的色调。多年来，他们用过各种不同的颜色，从更耀眼的纯白色到目前的灰色。人们觉得那是白色的，但实际上它是灰色的。在被授予地标建筑地位后，古根海姆经历了一次修复，这在油漆方面带来了一个有趣的难题：博物馆应该坚持每个人都已经习惯的浅灰色，还是时光倒流……
and repaint the Guggenheim the original yellow buff color? In the end, they chose light gray. It's the color everyone associates with the museum today. The second thing to know about the facade is that it's not structural. The concrete just hangs off the framework of the building and doesn't hold anything up. It's super thin. In places the concrete is less than five inches thick. There are notes in the archives warning workers not to use nails that are too long when hanging the artwork. The nails could go right through to the outside. Okay, stay right here. This is the second cafe stop.
把古根海姆重新粉刷成最初的黄色？最后，他们选择了浅灰色。这是今天每个人都与这座博物馆联系在一起的颜色。关于外立面的第二件事是，它不是结构性的。混凝土只是悬挂在建筑的框架上，并没有支撑任何东西。它非常薄。在某些地方，混凝土厚度不到五英寸。档案馆里有字条警告工人在悬挂艺术品时不要使用太长的钉子。钉子可能会直接穿透到外面。好了，就站在这里。这是第二个咖啡馆站。
So right now you're in the cafe, which are also standing on the third floor of a second smaller rotunda. I know it doesn't look like it, right? Originally, Frank Lloyd Wright wanted all of the Guggenheim staff to work in this building. He called this space the monitor, although nobody's entirely sure why. I really couldn't find a good description, but Frank Lloyd Wright always referred to it as the monitor in all correspondences. Like he really dubbed it that. My guess is that because it was the administrative building, it's kind of monitoring everyone else.
所以现在你在咖啡馆里，这也正站在第二个较小圆形大厅的三楼。我知道看起来不像，对吧？最初，弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特希望古根海姆所有的员工都在这栋楼里工作。他把这个空间叫做“监视器（the monitor）”，虽然没有人完全确定原因。我实在找不到一个好的描述，但弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特在所有的信件中都一直称它为监视器。就像他真的给它起了这个外号一样。我猜是因为它是行政大楼，它有点在监控其他所有人。
People used to have desks and lamps and family photos and they sat right where you're standing. But it was a pretty cramped space and awkwardly shaped. This overall almond slash football shape that you see is a stairwell. That shape kind of repeats throughout the building. And all of this is original. It's always been here. So if you're trying to imagine this being an office space,
过去人们有桌子、台灯和全家福照片，他们就坐在你现在站的地方。但这是一个相当狭窄且形状尴尬的空间。你看到的这种整体杏仁状/橄榄球状的结构是一个楼梯间。这种形状在整栋建筑中反复出现。所有这些都是原汁原味的。它一直都在这里。所以如果你试图想象这里是一个办公空间……
everything had to work around these forms. The offices were kind of like railroad apartments. There was no hallway, so if you had a desk at the back window, you had to walk through everyone else's office just to go to lunch. Today the museum staff mostly work off-site in a downtown location, and the monitor has become public gallery space, and home to the Guggenheim Cafe and GIF Shop. Now, you see that low wall in the corner, the one that looks like a balcony, will walk over there and take a look down. You'll see a gallery.
一切都必须围绕这些形态展开。这些办公室有点像铁路公寓。这里没有走廊，所以如果你的办公桌在后窗旁边，你必须穿过其他所有人的办公室才能去吃午饭。今天，博物馆的工作人员大多在市中心的一个场外地点办公，而“监视器”已经变成了公共展廊空间，也是古根海姆咖啡馆和礼品店的所在地。现在，你看到角落里的那堵矮墙了吗？那个看起来像阳台的墙，走过去往下看。你会看到一个展廊。
That gallery is actually part of a ten-story tower that's connected to the museum. You probably didn't notice the tower behind the main building when you came in. Nobody does. And that's kind of the point. It was built in 1992 by the architecture firm Guathmei Siegel, and it replaced an older tower built by Frank Lloyd Wright's son-in-law. The problem with the old tower was that it was just a bit much. Ashley pulled out a photo of it and just listened to her try to describe it.
那个展廊实际上与博物馆相连的一座十层塔楼的一部分。当你进来时，你可能没有注意到主楼后面的那座塔楼。没有人会注意到。这正是关键所在。它由建筑事务所 Gwathmey Siegel 于 1992 年建造，取代了由弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的女婿建造的旧塔楼。旧塔楼的问题在于它实在有点太过了。阿什利拿出一张它的照片，听听她是怎么描述它的。
So this tower is kind of two intersecting boxes, one tall vertical box which is the elevator core and then this rectangular box which is candlely bird so it's hanging off of that thing and both of them have these vertical stripes, hexagonal windows, just a pattern of hexagons all over the pison. It's wild too because I feel like it's completely fallen out of everyone's memory. Seriously look it up on your phone or when you get home it was wild. It looks a bit like 70s sci-fi architecture. I kind of love it but it actually stole attention away from the museum. And the Guathme Siegel Tower does such a good job of just looking like it was always meant to be there
所以这座塔有点像两个相交的盒子，一个是高高的垂直盒子，也就是电梯井，然后是这个悬挑的矩形盒子——它是悬挂在那个东西上面的，而且它们都有这些垂直条纹、六边形窗户，整个建筑外表到处都是六边形的图案。这太疯狂了，而且我觉得它已经完全从所有人的记忆中淡出了。说真的，在手机上查一下或者等你回家后看看，它太疯狂了。它看起来有点像 70 年代的科幻建筑。我有点喜欢它，但它确实抢了博物馆的风头。而 Gwathmey Siegel 塔楼做得非常出色，它看起来就像是一直属于那里……
and allowing the original Frank Lloyd Wright building to really shine. It just acts as a backdrop. And so I think that's why that design is so great. We're going to place a billboard right here in the middle of the Guggenheim, so we can pass and build. We'll be right back. The next stop is by the fourth floor elevators on the main ramp. Take a look at the ramp you're standing on. If you hang a picture with a slanted floor like this one, how would you do it? Would you make it straight? Or would you try to hang it to match the angle of the floor?
并且让最初的弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特建筑真正大放异彩。它只是充当一个背景。所以我觉得这个设计太棒了。我们将在古根海姆的正中间放置一块广告牌，以便我们通过和建造。我们马上回来。下一站位于主坡道四楼的电梯旁。看看你正站着的坡道。如果你在一面像这样倾斜的地板上挂画，你会怎么做？你会把它挂直吗？还是会试着让它顺应地板的角度来悬挂？
Franklin Wright designed a third option. He made bays throughout the building which slope backwards where you can hang paintings. Right really thought about a Bay as a comprehensive display system, so the back wall is at an angle approximately 105 degrees, which is really similar to an easel. The problem with the easel plan is that it's hard to look at paintings when they're tilting away from you. That's not how artists and curators wanted it. Look out into the rotunda. If the exhibition on display right now has paintings, you'll notice that many of them appear to be floating in space.
弗兰克·赖特设计了第三种选择。他在整个建筑中设计了向后倾斜的凹壁（bays），你可以在那里挂画。赖特真的把凹壁看作是一个综合的展示系统，所以后墙处于大约 105 度的倾斜角度，这非常类似于一个画架。画架计划的问题在于，当画作向后倾斜时，很难看清它们。这并不是艺术家和策展人想要的。望向圆形大厅。如果正在展出的展览有画作，你会注意到其中许多画作似乎悬浮在太空中。
That's the Guggenheim's signature way of hanging paintings. You can't see the hanging mechanism mechanism it's hiding behind the painting. If we were able to get a real, on a real angle and look back, you would be able to see where that hanging mechanism is and all of it is behind there. And so that's why you get that really nice shadow there. And the shadow doesn't have any of the hanging mechanism.
那是古根海姆悬挂画作的标志性方式。你看不到悬挂机构，它藏在画作后面。如果我们能够处于一个真实的倾斜角度并往回看，你就能看到悬挂机构在哪里，所有这些都在后面。这就是为什么你在那里能得到一个非常漂亮的阴影。而且阴影里没有任何悬挂机构。
It's just the piece itself. I'm not gonna sugarcoat this. The installation team has a very hard job here. They have to figure out a new plan for each work of art and for each part of the building because the bays get larger as you go up. Now here's another thing about the rotunda. If you look up, you'll see works of art.
只有作品本身。我不会粉饰这一点。这里的布展团队有一项非常艰巨的工作。他们必须为每一件艺术品和建筑的每一个部分想出一个新方案，因为随着楼层的升高，凹壁会变得越来越大。现在关于圆形大厅还有一件事。如果你抬头看，你会看到艺术品。
If you look across, you'll see works of art there too. Down there's more art. You're surrounded by art. Nancy Specter is the artistic director and Jennifer and David Stockman chief curator at the Guggenheim. There's some people who can be a religious experience. It's so profound to stand there with that work of art or works of art. Then, on top of that, you have the ability to look across the rotunda and see where
如果你看对面，你也会看到那里的艺术品。下面还有更多艺术品。你被艺术品包围了。南希·斯派克特 (Nancy Spector) 是古根海姆的艺术总监，詹妮弗和大卫·斯托克曼首席策展人。对某些人来说，这可能是一种宗教体验。与那件或那些艺术品站在一起是如此深远。除此之外，你还有机会环顾圆形大厅，看看……
you're going and where you've come from. So you have a chance to revisit from a distance. The Guggenheim is the only museum in town without a backstage area where staff can prepare new exhibits. And that means if you come during a change of a period between exhibitions, you get to see the new exhibit taking shape right before your eyes. Nancy says installing art in the Guggenheim is a totally unique challenge, but it's a challenge she loves. My education has been in a round building with very strange leaning walls and inclined ramps, so it is my normal. I've always spoken
你要去哪里以及你来自哪里。所以你有机会从远处重温。古根海姆是城里唯一没有后台区域的博物馆，员工无法在那里准备新的展览。这意味着如果你在展览交替的间隙期间来，你就能亲眼见证新展览在你眼前成型。南希说，在古根海姆安装艺术品是一个完全独一无二的挑战，但这是一个她热爱的挑战。我的教育背景是在一栋有着非常奇怪的倾斜墙壁和倾斜坡道的圆形建筑里度过的，所以这是我的常态。我一直将……
about the building as a catalyst and that it challenges us over and over and over again. And one of those challenges is that Nancy has to literally walk laps around the building to see if the placement of each work of art is just right. When you're installing, you're constantly walking around the circle. It changes at every vantage point, so one has to kind of understand that. The progression of the continuous ramp encourages viewers to look at each piece of art in a particular order. The order of the art tells a story. In terms of the structure of the museum, it really invites sequential looking. In a way that a square or
这座建筑视为一个催化剂，它一次又一次、不间断地挑战我们。其中一个挑战就是，南希必须字面意义上绕着建筑走圈，以查看每一件艺术品的位置是否恰到好处。当你布展时，你一直在绕着圆圈走。它在每一个视角的观感都在改变，所以人们必须理解这一点。连续坡道的进程鼓励观众按特定的顺序观看每一件艺术品。艺术品的顺序讲述了一个故事。就博物馆的结构而言，它确实引发了连续的观看。以一种方形或……
rectangular room doesn't. I really do like building a story making an argument in space that for me having worked here for so long it's easier to do on the ramps which again unfolds sequentially versus a room that basically tells you the story immediately. But you, as a visitor to the Guggenheim, also have control over the story. You can choose to take in the art across the rotunda or the bay right in front of you. You can follow along with the story being told or choose your own adventure and see what you discover. The next stop is by the 5th Floor Elevators on the main ramp.
矩形房间所没有的方式。我真的很喜欢在空间中构建一个故事、阐述一个观点，对我来说，在这个地方工作了这么久，在坡道上做这件事更容易，因为坡道再次展现了顺序性，而不像那种能立刻向你讲述整个故事的房间。但作为古根海姆的游客，你也可以掌控这个故事。你可以选择欣赏圆形大厅对面的艺术品，或是你正前方的凹壁。你可以跟随讲述的故事，也可以选择你自己的冒险并看看你能发现什么。下一站位于主坡道五楼的电梯旁。
My name is Christopher George on the Director of the Fabrication Department. Richard Avery, senior facilities manager. Christopher and Richard are part of the team that installs new exhibitions in this building. They've hung full-sized cars and oversized cat skeletons to fill the center void. In this unusual space, each exhibition is a feat of engineering that has to be planned perfectly, but there's only so much planning that can happen. Obviously, there's no Guggenheim roadtunder that we can go to, you know, in practice. We make the best with the spaces available and then hopefully everything comes together well and it's time for the actual installation.
我叫克里斯托弗·乔治 (Christopher George)，是制作部门主管。理查德·埃弗里 (Richard Avery)，高级设施经理。克里斯托弗和理查德是负责在这座建筑中安装新展览的团队成员。他们曾在中心虚空中悬挂过全尺寸汽车和超大猫科动物骨骼。在这个不同寻常的空间里，每一个展览都是一项必须完美规划的工程壮举，但能做的规划终究是有限的。很显然，我们没有一个可以去实践的古根海姆圆形大厅，你知道的。我们只能尽最大努力利用现有空间，然后希望一切顺利结合，迎来真正的布展时刻。
Once you solve the problem of hanging a chandelier made of nine cars, you do not want to have to start from scratch the next time an artist wants to display something audacious and rotunda. So some of the anchor points are still left in place. Look up. There are concrete support walls that are called web walls that hold up the whole building and converge in the skyline. If you look very carefully, you'll notice stainless steel circles all over them. Those are rigging points. Places where cables and pulleys have been attached over the years.
一旦你解决了悬挂由九辆车组成的枝形吊灯的问题，当下次艺术家想在圆形大厅展示一些更大胆的东西时，你就不想从头开始了。所以有些锚点仍然保留在原位。抬头看。有被称为网墙的混凝土支撑墙，它们支撑着整栋建筑并在天际线处交汇。如果你仔细观察，你会注意到上面到处都是不锈钢圆圈。那些是吊装点。多年来一直用于连接缆绳和滑轮的地方。
Each point has a name. So we've actually named them according to the artists that they were initially installed for. So we have rigging points that we call the Flavin Points. For when there's the Flavin Light Tower installed, we have themging points that we call the Flavin Points for when there's the Flavin Light Tower installed. We have them for Frank Gary, the Gary Points from when we installed sets of hanging aluminum. Throughout the museum, there are lots of bolts and hooks that unveil how old exhibitions were displayed.
每个点都有一个名字。所以我们实际上是根据它们最初为之安装的艺术家来命名的。所以我们有被称为“弗莱文点 (Flavin Points)”的吊装点。那是为了安装弗莱文灯塔时设立的；我们有被称为“盖瑞点 (Gary Points)”的吊装点，那是为了安装悬挂铝制装置时设立的。整个博物馆里有许多螺栓和挂钩，它们揭示了过去的展览是如何展示的。
These are the leftovers of something amazing that happened here. It's not just on the ceilings and walls, the floors happen too. As you walk on the ramps, look down to the Toronto floor. You'll see a lot of dark circular depressions in the floor. Installing level sculptures on a slanted floor requires a lot of forethought and power tools. Say for installing pedestals or platforms or stanchions or even some pieces of art, they need to be a fix to the floor. But here's the thing with this slope floor. If a sculpture needs to be moved for any reason, you can't just pick up the pedestal and shift it
这些是这里发生过的精彩事件的遗迹。不仅天花板和墙壁上有，地板上也有。当你走在坡道上时，看看大理石水磨石（terrazzo）地板。你会看到地上有很多深色的圆形凹陷。在倾斜的地板上安装水平的雕塑需要大量的深谋远虑和电动工具。比方说安装底座、平台、支柱甚至某些艺术品，它们都需要固定在地板上。但问题来了，面对这个倾斜的地板：如果由于某种原因需要移动雕塑，你不能只拿起底座然后把它挪动……
a couple inches. The angle might be wrong. So you have to recut the whole pedestal and do it over again, affixing it to the floor at another point. That's why the anchor points in the floor aren't as reusable from exhibition to exhibition. There's no point in leaving them there, so the Guggenheim fixes them. But fully repairing the Tarazo isn't easy. There are only a few companies that know how to fix this kind of flooring, including one guy who has worked with the Guggenheim. His name is Larry, Larry's good, but unfortunately, Larry is now retired. We're having him actually train some of the museum staff so that we'll still have the skill
几英寸。角度可能会不对。所以你必须重新切割整个底座并重来一遍，将其固定在楼盘的另一个点上。这就是为什么地板上的锚点在不同展览之间并不能那么重复使用。把它们留在那里没有意义，所以古根海姆会修复它们。但彻底修复水磨石并非易事。只有少数几家公司知道如何修复这种地板，其中包括一位曾与古根海姆合作过的人。他的名字叫拉里 (Larry)。拉里很棒，但不幸的是，拉里现在退休了。我们正让他实际培训一些博物馆员工，以便我们仍然掌握这门手艺，能够自己继续这些修复工作。
set in hand to continue with these repairs ourselves. These divots and pockmarks are ghosts, tiny reminders of past exhibitions. Some you done yourself and you kind of remember putting those holes in the floor, but one day they'll all be gone and they'll just be memories. The final stop is by the 6th floor elevators on the main ramp. When you reach the final revolution at the top of the spiral ramp, look down at the Tarazo floor. You'll notice that the pattern changes. Most of the floor in the ramp has a repeating circular pattern, but at this point, the pattern
这些凹痕和麻点是幽灵，是过去展览的微小提醒。有些是你自己弄的，你还记得在地上砸出那些洞的情景，但有一天它们都会消失，只剩下回忆。最后一站位于主坡道六楼的电梯旁。当你到达螺旋坡道顶部的最后一次旋转时，低头看看水磨石地板。你会注意到图案变了。坡道上的大部分地板都有重复的圆形图案，但在这一点上，图案……
turns to square. And so that initially showed the boundary between public and private space. In the early days of the Guggenheim, you could not go past this line. There's some debate as to what Frank Lloyd Wright wanted, but as best we can tell, this part was not supposed to be gallery space. This was never exhibition space, which hard for you to imagine. It's so beautiful up here, everyone loves these spaces. In the early days, this space was used for storage,
变成了方形。这最初显示了公共空间和私人空间之间的分界线。在古根海姆的早期，你是不能越过这条线的。关于弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特想要什么有一些争论，但据我们所知，这部分本不应该是展廊空间。这从来都不是展览空间，这很难让你想象。这里上面太美了，每个人都喜欢这些空间。在早期，这个空间是用来储藏的……
but here it is now, open to the public, and you have a lovely opportunity to transgress and trespass into what was once forbidden territory. Do it with me. Take one step over into the squares. According to the original plans, you were not supposed to be here. Now step back.
但现在它对公众开放了，你有一个绝佳的机会去僭越和闯入曾经是禁区的地方。跟我一起做。迈出一步，跨入方形区域内。根据最初的计划，你不应该在这里。现在退后一步。
The ghost of Franklin Wright is at peace. Okay, step over again into the forbidden zone. Look at you, you urban explorer feels good, doesn't it? Now step back and keep going, back and forth, and dance with the Guggenheim. If there is any piece of architecture worth dancing about, this is it. This tour of the Guggenheim Museum, which I called an audio guide to the imperfections of Frank Lloyd Wright's perfect masterpiece was produced by me Roman Mars, Chris Barube and Sophia Klatsker. Mixing tech production by Srivusif, music by Sean Riel. Special thanks to everyone at the Guggenheim Museum for allowing me to make this, especially
弗兰克·赖特的灵魂得到了安息。好的，再次跨入禁区。看看你，你这个城市探险家，感觉不错吧？现在退回去，继续前进，来回走动，与古根海姆共舞。如果有任何建筑值得为之跳舞，那就是这座。这次古根海姆博物馆之旅——我称之为弗兰克·赖特完美杰作中不完美之处的语音导游——由我和罗曼·马尔斯、克里斯·巴鲁贝 (Chris Barube) 以及索菲亚·克拉茨克 (Sophia Klatsker) 共同制作。混音制作由 Srivusif 负责，音乐由肖恩·里尔 (Sean Riel) 创作。特别感谢古根海姆博物馆的每一个人，感谢他们允许我制作这个节目，尤其是……
Caitlin Dover and Laura Cleger who cooked up this whole idea and Ashley Mendelssohn for being our guide in this guide. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org.
感谢构思了这个主意的Caitlin Dover和Laura Cleger，以及带领我们领略这一切的Ashley Mendelssohn。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的Radio Row。“99%可听”是来自PRX的Radio Topia成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚独立集体。请访问radiotopia.fm了解详情。您可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。您可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars），或者@节目官方账号99PI org。
We're on Instagram and Reddit too. We have pictures of the different Guggenheim Museum stops and all kinds of fun stuff. at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。我们在99pi.org上发布了古根海姆博物馆各个停靠点的照片以及各种有趣的内容。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。